hohoho meine kleinen luca weihnachts
helferinnen ich darf euch heute herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einer weiteren
episode wir packen unsere mobile
kalender aus noch so rund dass mit ihr
schon richtig weihnachtlich weil das
gras in zwei seite meine lieben freunde
ich darf euch heute mal wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen endlich zu
einer neuen episode e mails mit luca
hallo ich hätte einen job für sie wird
sie für 450 euro zweimal die woche gassi
gehen so etwa zwei stunden wäre an der
konsti liebe grüße was ist das denn für
eine hunderasse
es handelt sich dabei um mich
danach so aber kannst du mir einen
gefallen tun und einen perso mitbringen
damit ich ein foto machen kann das
letzte fahrrad das sich auf ebay gekauft
habt war geklaut und wurde mir von den
polen abgenommen ich bin staatenlos
sorry
da bin ich wieder hallo kann man nur die
lange rannten und 20 kilogramm gewicht
kaufen also ohne die kurz hatte und die
hantelbank ich werde mich sehr freuen
wenn sie ja sagen nein
und ich sag bitte redet wie ein mensch
da costa haben caritas mehr drum
ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt wieder
die wir hier gelandet sind und das frage
ich mich auch beim nächsten liebefeld
denn hier tauscht jemand seine mutter
gegen eine playstation fünf verkaufe
meine mutter die verbietet mir eine ps 5
deswegen tausche ich sie gegen eine ps 5
ich weiß 500 anrufe menschenrechte sind
sämtlich abstoßen oder auch hier
hier suchte mich jemand seine ps 5 für
seine katze die bald geburtstag hat ja
beruhigt das so süß geschrieben war mit
dem geburtstag seiner katze habe ich dir
hier im gebot für den ps 5 rausgesucht
das kostet auch nur in etwa so viel wie
ein einfamilienhaus und wenn du dann
noch einen lautsprecher für die
playstation 5 benötigt habe ich hier
auch ein passendes angebot für dich
kostet 20 euro sieht halt so aus so kann
ein bisschen warm werden
versteht ihr
als nächstes haben wir hier auch einen
passenden controller für die playstation
5 beziehungsweise einen defekten
controller für die xbox oder playstation
4 und auf dem foto sieht man es war ein
playstation 3 controller der passt schon
für die ps 5 dass das abwärtskompatibel
ja jetzt setzt er noch voll mit spucke
mein mikro hier und hier auch dann würde
ich nicht so
hallo junger mann würde schuh zusammen
mit batterie gehen meine cousine aus
kasachstan wechseln sie gut küche und
gute körper hat auch probiert warte
was hast du probiert habe probiert ihr
küche und ihr körper
neda klatsch einfach nicht es ist
bereits nächstes verkaufte jemand ein
gebrauchtes macbook pro und ein
interessent fragt den verkäufer hey 700
euro sind richtig ja die 700 euro sind
richtig war auch alles klar
hätte ja sein können abholung in
zensiert nee du stellst dass bei
mcdonald sondern liefert das ubs der
periode gut ich frag doch nur kein grund
gleich so rumzuhacken ich kacke in
fremde rucksäcke
hallo ich hätte interesse an ihrem
fahrzeug welcher hand sind sie denn
rechts
der meint nicht ob erster hand
das nächste person meine lieben freunde
ist unternehmer durch und durch das
komplette money business durchgespielt
denn er verkauft für fünf euro das er
bei deiner ex auf install kommentiert
ich kommentiere etf bei deinem ex auf
install
das ist wirklich der der erste richtig
gute ebay bei der stuhl ist noch zu
haben liebe grüße leute die allein who
als begrüßung schreiben allerdings
kowski am ende auf jeden fall ist der
stuhl noch zu haben und daraufhin fragt
der wie viel rabatt geben sie denn am
black friday gar keinen das ist ein
festpreis ihnen ist klar dass sie am
blacks weiter als gewerblicher verkäufer
verpflichtet sind ihren kunden ein
rabatt zu gewähren jeder macht dass
außer ihnen mit 40 prozent wäre ich
einverstanden heute ist wirklich black
friday denn für ihr angebot sehe ich
leider schwarz
jetzt wagen ganz kurze werbung
zwischendurch meine lieben freunde nicht
für den lukasz obwohl da demnächst auch
neue klamotten rauskommen nähe sondern
meine liebe freunde wenn ihr noch ein
geschenk für eure eltern sucht kann ich
euch dass sie nur empfehlen das ist eine
dekoration der toilettenschüssel extrem
hygienisch und kostet 20 euro
guten abend entschuldigen sie bitte ich
wollte es ihnen heute morgen versenden
aber meine eltern wussten es nicht dass
ich das verkaufen und habe dadurch einen
streit ausgelöst und zwar meine eltern
möchten den jetzt nicht mehr verkaufen
da sie möchten es selbst behalten meine
eltern sind die besten für mich und
möchte sie nicht traurig lassen ich
zahle ihnen ihr geld zurück per paypal
und gäbe noch 20 euro
so süß
du bist auf jeden fall der ehemann der
woche und er hier nicht
er verkauft die hälfte einer walnuss
schale für drei euro und dann bin ich
mal auf seinem profil gegangen bei ebay
und er verkauft nur sowas der verkauft
auch so gebogenen nägel oder seifen
karton zum basteln oder pub rohre und
notizzettel und dann halt immer für den
70 fachen preis erste idee programm
nächstenliebe fällen wollte sich eine
person auf ebay anmelden und irgendwie
war da wohl ein bisschen schrott was die
sprache angeht auf jeden fall konnte sie
auswählen zwischen den geschlechtern her
frau und taucher und hier verkauft
jemand einen wasserkocher und toaster
und schreibt deswegen den anzeigen namen
russell hobbs wasserkocher und thorsten
das sind so sachen da kann ich einfach
nicht mehr drüber lachen genauso geht es
mir auch bei dem hier meine lieben
freunde hey wurden die schuhe überall
getragen sind damit auch zigaretten aus
getreten worden hallo
sie wurden selten getragen und wenn nur
auf der öffentlichen straße
nein zigaretten wurden nicht ausgetreten
war zuletzt getragen vor drei monaten ok
sehr gut suchen nämlich solche schuhe
die in der korona zeit getragen wurden
daher okay hoffe noch nicht gewaschen
und gereinigt warum er werde ich die
dann ungereinigt haben möchte pro
das macht vorne und hinten keinen sinn
der ich hätte gerne das auto oder das
ist mega gut
das könnten sie auch komplett neu
bekommen 0 kilometern gefahren und hätte
das gerne schon so richtig eingefahren
ok also sie meinen jetzt die ersten zwei
3000 kilometer oder weil wir so 2
millionen
können sie da auch noch im kopf
apropos auto allerdings meine lieben
freunde hier verkauft die man einen
volkswagen golf und ein interessent
fragt ihn was sagen sie zu 1100 euro
ohne reifen das auto wird nur mit reifen
verkaufte mein letzter preis bleibt bei
1350 das auto werde im laufe nächster
woche abholbereit warum worauf bezieht
sich das warum auf ihr auto ich kenne
den reifen ansonsten nichts mehr
anfangen die gehören zu meinem angebot
ich kann die reifen behalten aber
dadurch mindere den preisen nicht dann
behalten sie die reifen und ich gebe
ihnen 1250 und einen döner awo möchte
kein döner aber ich würde gerne für das
auto 1350 euro haben aber er schmeckt
gut und ist gut
ich kann mir das nicht mehr geben hier
wir machen noch einen letzten email
fällen ist der hier meine lieben freunde
da verkauft jemand ein günstiges saturn
ein interessent schreibt ihm hallo ich
will mich auch unterarm tätowieren
lassen was kostet das was für ein motiv
und wie groß so gerne würde ich mich
erstmal von niemand tätowieren lassen
der nicht mal richtig schreiben kann der
name meines kindes circa zehn zentimeter
so 40 euro kann es morgen kommen adresse
bla bla bla bla bla die woche schlecht
gehen auch nächste woche da kann ich
nicht muss ab freitag in haft
[Musik]
hey